it's remarkable that today it's taken
totally for granted and it's a foregone
conclusion that people tweet along with
broadcasts what's really interesting is
that this kind of virtual roar of the
crowd is happening during the broadcast
window in most cases Twitter's chief
media scientist deb roy came up with a
metaphor for this phenomenon over the
roar of the crowd on twitter and on
mobile which he calls the social
soundtrack so this is the germ of what
what inspired the name amplified Twitter
amplify as we basically asked ourselves
how can we make that sound track a
little bit louder and here's what it
looks like in action this was one of the
most talked about moments of last year's
NBA season so there was a sustained roar
of the crowd over this particular play
Jack Dorsey one of the cofounders of
Twitter describes a tweet as a caption
to a much larger context we wanted to
actually bring that context in the tweet
in real time and here's what it looks
like
the announcers half the fun and the idea
here is that the NBA the rights holder
is obviously providing the the broadcast
through their broadcast partner and
that's the first screen and you can see
here the social soundtrack of the folks
watching and tweeting about it during
the broadcast window sharing this
conversation with other people who are
tweeting about it and on and on etc now
what the idea for amplify is in this
kind of idea of real-time video is that
at the same time complementary to this
we can actually target a clip from the
game in real time right after the dunk
of the block out to someone who may have
forgotten the tune in and similarly we
can feed that clip straight into the
existing conversation at the moment when
it speaking during that broadcast window
like you saw at the beginning and then
here obviously it's kind of a visual
representation of what we mean by
amplify this virtuous cycle created by
feeding this existing conversation with
real-time clips amplifies main use cases
come out of sports and that we
originally thought of as instant replays
but it's not the only one and it
actually started with inspiration from
the east coast earthquake from a few
years ago so here's a visualization of
what it looked like for tweets to travel
around the eastern seaboard when the
East Coast earthquake happened these
graphs here actually nuts aren't seismic
readings they look like it but those are
actually the y axis is tweets so you can
see the tweets traveling anticipating
the shock wave coming through so we
started really nerding out on
earthquakes and twitter and we found
this particular account in chile that
was created by a 15 year old who hooked
a seismograph up directly to a twitter
account so we're like wow ok tweeting
objects this is pretty cool what else
can we find then discover this account
which is a pollution meter on top of the
US Embassy in Beijing one of the only
accounts technically in China that
actually isn't blocked this pollution
meter actually tweets out air pollution
levels automatically in Beijing on a
regular basis a couple years ago there's
a minor diplomatic dust up when this
device couldn't actually process the
level of pollution in the air on a
certain day and it actually revealed an
easter egg and however this thing was
programmed and it just tweeted out crazy
bad
sometimes the tweeting objects have
personalities so we tried to think of
how do we get this tweeting object into
the world of brands and here's what we
came up with with our partners again at
the NBA right at the moment when the
dunk happens the backboard itself has a
Twitter account and tweets out a picture
of itself getting dunked on and then a
lot of things start happening that we
didn't anticipate at all we started
having partners come to us with ideas
for using this idea of to screen video
that went way beyond instant replays you
can start to see some of the brand
integrations here this is Duracell
sponsoring a live weather map by the
weather channel that they tweet it out
to people in cities about to get hit by
storms obviously from a brand
integration point of view really
creative and news you can use like go
buy batteries because you're going to be
out of power soon so imagine that level
of artfulness in that level of care and
that level of imagination applied to
anything you can see on TV and imagine
if the control room for all the TVs live
or taped etc were constantly pumping out
second screen content it's really just
the beginning and the best part about it
is that the storytelling on TV already
as this magazine said of here goes in
its platinum age at the exact same time
smartphones are making TV even better
than it than it is and we don't a
Twitter think of ourselves as rival
wrist TV and we think of our position
with respect to TV to be very modest
basically just a way to connect the
audience with the with the creators on
the screen we tapped into something
unknowingly that was this hunger for
this ability to tell stories across two
screens